ressentez-vous ce qu'il se passe entre
vous et moi
entre nous il se passe quelque chose
entre nous à travers nous circulent des
énergies des forces d'attraction des
force de répulsion partout ces énergies
s'agite sans cesse dans l'espace alors
peut-être allez-vous me prendre pour un
illuminé
si je vous dit être sensible à des
phénomènes imperceptible je ne suis pas
un médium ce que je fais je suis artiste
alors oui artiste excentrique illuminé
lorsqu'on est artiste les critiques sur
notre quotidien mais cela ne me dérange
pas vraiment car je me sens je me sens
excentrique et illuminer un beau écrit
en 1871 dans une lettre je vous dis
d'être voyant soyons voyant selon le
philosophe henri bergson
l'artiste est un voyant c'est à dire
qu'ils voient ce que les autres hommes
ne vois pas ce qu ils n'aperçoivent pas
naturellement et leurs oeuvres le leur
font voir nous avons un rôle de messager
de transmetteurs comme illuminé
je dirais être une sorte de voyants
lumineux alors attention mesdames et
messieurs je vais vous montrer ce que je
vois lorsque je retourne lorsque je
regarde autour de moi devant moi qu'est
ce que je vois je vois du monde
vous dégagez des énergies de la chaleur
vous êtes là vous organes travail
vous êtes composé 200 de tissus dos de
molécules d'eau nous sommes de la
matière des particules des actes des
atomes qui s'agitent à la fois je peux
vous voir comme une masse comme une
forme en mouvement ou me focaliser sur
quelques individus et faire abstraction
de tout ce qui se trouveront au tour ma
tête est amovible et mon champ de vision
variable je reviens à mes pieds ici à
mes pieds je vois ces blocs ces grosses
lettres t e d et x de couleur rouge
rouge écarlate
je suis curieux je me posais la question
pourquoi ce rouge écarlate
pourquoi pas un vermillon et pourquoi
pas une autre couleur quel est ce choix
qu'il a choisi ce rouge
ce rouge nous ne le voyons pas forcément
tous de la même manière sans partir dans
une multitude d'interprétations pour un
scientifique il se dirait que cette
couleur est visible simplement parce
qu'elle est éclairé par de la lumière
dans le noir
voilà le rouge est il toujours rouge
et bien cette couleur est simplement un
degré de longueur d'onde du spectre
électromagnétique visible par l'oeil
humain
au-delà de ces degrés il y at il autre
chose
eh bien oui au delà du violet vous aurez
l'ultraviolet au delà de l'ultraviolet
les rayons x les rayons gamma et au delà
du rouge l'infra bush et les ondes radio
il y à la partie visibles et non
visibles
ce qui n'est pas perceptible par l'oeil
humain à chaque fois lorsque je regarde
autour de moi mon environnement
je ne peux pas m'empêcher de me poser
tout un tas de questions comme ça que ce
soit en regardant le monde
le mouvement les formes la lumière ou
simplement en me penchant au dessus
d'une flaque d'eau croupie et observant
cette petite riche vie aquatique dans si
peu d espaces en songeant tu as qu'on ne
peut pas voir un jour je me suis dit
mais les scientifiques ont justement des
instruments qui permet de voir plus près
de voir plus loin de voir différemment à
des seychelles microscopique jusqu'à d
échelle macroscopique
alors je n'ai pas attendu longtemps
encore étudiant à l'école supérieure des
beaux-arts de tours je me suis décidé à
contacter le monde scientifique alors un
étudiant en art tu veux rencontrer des
scientifiques ok c'est un monde plutôt
larges et variés la science vers quels
domaines m'orienter je m'intéresse à pas
mal de domaines j'y vois beaucoup de
connexions
mais la science qui me passionne le plus
celle qui pour moi est l'une des plus
abstraite à l'origine de tout
l'astronomie non loin de tours
se trouve paumé en sologne vraiment dans
un coin perdu un endroit assez spécial
la station de radioastronomie de nançay
alors simplement je leur envoyais une
lettre je leur envoyais à courrier
électromagnétiques
je suis rentré en contact avec les
scientifiques alors l'astronomie hockey
l'astronomie ok mais la radioastronomie
qu'est ce que la radioastronomie et bien
c'est l'étude en astronomie par
observation du ciel dans le domaine des
ondes radio juste avant en vous parlant
de lumière en vous parlant du rouge
je vous avais dit qu'il y avait là fera
mouche et après les ondes radio alors
non ce ne sont pas les fréquences fm et
am de votre poste radio vous avez tous à
la maison qui sont étudiées par les
chercheurs à la station ils étudient
dans d'autres bandes de fréquences sur
ce schéma
vous pouvez voir il ya le spectre
visible de la lumière
les bandes de fréquences visible il y a
aussi les ondes radio qui sont
observables depuis la terre car elles ne
sont pas bloquées par l'atmosphère les
autres les uv les rayons x les rayons
gamma sont observés depuis l'espace les
chercheurs à nançay étudie à travers les
ondes radio l'univers et son évolution à
partir des âges sombres c'est à dire
plusieurs millions d'années après le big
bang la formation des galaxies et des
amas de galaxies les pulsars et autres
sources aux transitoires le soleil les
planètes les exoplanètes
c'est quand même assez surprenant que
l'étude des ondes radio découverte par
inadvertance il ya moins d'un siècle
dans les laboratoires bell
nous sommes arrivés aujourd'hui avoir
des instruments embarqués sur satellite
ayons pu faire une cartographie dans
l'infrarouge de l'image la plus ancienne
de l'univers le fond diffus cosmologique
c'est l'image de l'univers très jeune
environ 380 mille ans après le big bang
alors pour un artiste
comment s'imaginer travailler avec des
notions aussi vague à partir de
recherches basé sur l'imperceptible n'a
palpable eh bien je vais citer un
artiste coupe que vous connaissez tous
qui en sont envoyés en tout cas le ciel
à sa manière il s'agit de la nuit
étoilée de van gogh ici au centre
vous pouvez voir une spirale et bien
c'est une galaxie seuls des astronomes
peut-être y at-il des astronomes dans la
salle auront reconnu m51 le couple de
galaxie du tourbillon alors van gogh se
serait-il intéressé aux recherches
scientifiques
peut-être aurait-il pu aurait enfin se
serait-il inspiré de dessin d'astronomes
comme par exemple celui de l'ordre
hausse ici réalisée en 1845 ou de jean
chacornac 1862
jean pierre luminet astrophysicien
poètes artistes et auteurs contemporains
a pu dater la nuit devant gogh au petit
matin du 25 mai 1889 plus précisément
grâce au positionnement des étoiles et
de la lune dans la composition de sa
peinture
donc les formes qu'il aurait reproduit
dans sa peinture sont une
réinterprétation du ciel c'est à dire
une façon dont on ne pouvait pas voir à
l'époque c'est à dire autrement que par
un télescope dans la composition de sa
valse céleste il y a une forme d'énergie
de tension c'est comme ça en fait que
cet artiste représente est essentielle
pour de nombreux artistes
nous avons parfois des moments
d'égarement ce sont des moments intenses
nous ne sommes plus vraiment dans notre
corps ce ne sont pas des moments de
réflexion disons plutôt que nos pensées
s'évade s'évanouissent dans
l'environnement
arrivé à la station de radioastronomie
de nançay j'ai eu un instant ce
sentiment
le site se trouve perdu au milieu de la
sologne au coeur de la sologne dans
cette immensité de verdure se dresse ici
et là des géants métalliques aux lents
mouvements se dirigeant vers des sources
mystérieuse investi d'un projet dont je
ne donnais pas encore de forme
j'ai laissé mon imagination divaguer
entre le chant des oiseaux le vent
soufflant dans la forêt et cette vague
question
la dimension immatérielle que peuvent
avoir des ondes provenant du cosmos je
ne vais pas me perdre je vais me fondre
je vais créer mes propres antennes il y
a quelques années j'ai découvert sur une
radio en ligne un artiste contemporain
qui travaillent avec les ondes avec
l'invisible en traversant de magnifiques
paysages arctiques avec une antenne sept
artistes s'appellent jean pierre aubé et
m'a inspiré avec son antenne bricoler il
partait capter l'activité des aurores
boréales et les traduisent et en sons
cette dimension poétique du récolteurs
deux champs d'horreur j'ai voulu la
réaliser aussi moi même c'est à dire pas
au niveau des aurores boréales
mais imaginez un espace dans lequel dans
lequel on pourrait écouter l'activité
céleste
alors jean pierre aubé a pu nous faire
écouter les aurores terrestre annoncée
bientôt il sera possible d'entendre
l'activité des aurores de jupiter
ou de saturne
alors cet espace sonore qui sera situé à
l'extérieur au coeur du réseau
d'antennes
je devais lui trouver une forme c'est à
dire une forme qui pour moi représente
l'univers comme van gogh comme van gogh
c'est à dire de la façon dont je le vois
dont je le perçois pas évident il se
trouve qu'il ya une forme en topologie
qui depuis l'antiquité symbolise le
cosmos c'est l'un des cinq solides
platon le dodécaèdre 12 face pentagonale
régulière cette forme
ce solide peut s'inscrire dans une
sphère jean pierre luminet
l'astrophysicien dont je vous ai parlé
qui a adapté la nuit étoilée de van gogh
a émis l'hypothèse sur l'espace daudet
cas hydrique de poincaré pouvant être un
candidat potentiel à la forme globale de
l'univers cet espace sonore accueillant
du public pourrait donc avoir une forme
architecturale basé sur le dos des
cadres un architecte david georges
emmerich a élaborée dans les années 60
un système de structures qu'il appelait
auto tendu c'est à dire
qu'elle n'ait pas besoin de support
comme ces grosses colonnes que vous avez
autour de vous ces structures se tenait
d'elle-même et bien ce type de structure
que j'ai décidé de réactualiser
annonçait voici deux visuels de mon
projet à l'intérieur vous aurez une
spatialisation sonore
ce sont ce bruit ce sera une
retranscription d'après les données
captées par les antennes alors c'est à
dire on pourrait enfin on pourrait dire
le son du cosmos mais pas vraiment avant
de vous laisser je vais vous dire qu'en
fait il n'y a pas il n'y a pas de son
dans le cosmos il n'y a pas de son dans
l'univers ce sera ici comme une
traduction sonore de la lumière
invisible que nous et met les étoiles
alors maintenant en vous invitant à me
suivre au coeur de la forêt à rentrer
dans cet espace sonore c'est vous
inviter à une expérience à suivre
l'artiste
à suivre le scientifique à percevoir
différemment
voire par le son voir le ciel sous un
autre angle voir différemment